there's this house in this neighborhood
in New Jersey that actually isn't a
house it's hard to see because it's
behind this gate but if you look at it
from above you'll see that it's actually
a really large building kind of looks
like a warehouse it has dozens of air
conditioning units and it's just sitting
here among a sea of ordinary suburban
homes
all of this is just a facade hiding this
massive building that is a landing
station for a t the place where these
massive undersea cables that connect to
the world Hit the Eastern seaboard
we now know for certain that the U.S
government spies on those cables with
the help of companies like at T and
according to a leaked map from the NSA
they process all the data that they
collect somewhere in New Jersey in a
facility called pine cone lining up
these Maps points to this secretive
disguised building as one of the best
candidates for where this surveillance
is being processed but there's a lot
more of these hidden buildings around
the country thanks to leaked NSA
documents and some thorough
investigative reporting we now know some
of their locations like the fake house
in New Jersey these other cable spy
facilities blend in as benign
nondescript buildings avoiding any undue
attention along the streets of New York
or San Francisco or Dallas
these few hundred cables that connect
our world contain an unfathomable amount
of data all of our communication all of
our connections and it would seem
impossible that any government agency
would be able to spy on it all
impossible that is if we didn't have
solid proof that they do
so let me tell you the story of the
cables that connect our planet and show
you that if you can tap into them you
can watch the world and they have and
they've been doing it for a long time
320 million records every day what we're
talking about here is a total revolution
of the whole concept before collect it
all
exploit it all
now is the moment where I say thank you
to the sponsor of today's video I'm very
grateful for sponsors I wouldn't be able
to do this job and make independent
journalism if we didn't have sponsors so
thank you incogni for sponsoring today's
video incognate is actually quite
relevant to today's video because
incogni is super interested in data
privacy we live in a world where there's
an entire secretive industry dedicated
to collecting information about you and
no this isn't the NSA spying on you this
is for-profit corporations who spy on
you in any way they can so they can sell
that to other companies who can then
Market to you who can get into your
phone who can try to make you buy things
I find this incredibly frustrating and
violating that my personal information
is bought and sold on an open market
luckily we have rights to make this not
happen the problem is the process of
making it not happen is very complicated
and this gets me to incogni incogni is a
service that does this for you you sign
up for incognate and you give them
permission to go out into the world on
your behalf and take you off as many
lists as they can the first thing they
do and this is very satisfying is they
scan to see all of the lists that you're
on and they show it to you on this
really nice dashboard so you can see
like oh my God I'm on like dozens if not
hundreds of these marketing lists and
then they start the process of securing
your privacy of getting your email and
your address and your phone number off
these lists it's a process and incognate
will keep you updated on the progress
they even have a tally of like all of
the lists that you've been removed from
which is like insanely satisfying to
keep an eye on because of incogni I
learned that here in the US there's this
other massive problem which are these
people search sites where you can like
search for people and it will pull up as
much information as the site has on you
I don't like that incogni sniffed this
out for me and is taking me off of these
lists thank you incogni I'm very
grateful for it so there's a link in my
description it's incognito.com Johnny
Harris and you can go over sign up for
incogni and try it out for 30 days and
get a full refund and if you don't think
it's useful totally risk-free I'm really
grateful to incognate for sponsoring our
journalism and this video but I'm also
grateful that they exist because I am so
tired of my inbox and my phone and my
mailbox being full of garbage okay with
that we're jumping back into the video
about the government version of
collecting your data we laid the first
copper cable across the Atlantic Ocean
in 1858. it connected Ireland to Canada
they sent the first telegram across this
wire and it took 18 hours to arrive
which was like Lightspeed back then the
cable broke three weeks later but even
still it was a huge success a revolution
for a world whose progress hinged on
being more and more connected to a
single table only an engine report stick
which lies on the ocean today the planet
would be linked up by many more of these
cables draped along the ocean floor
allowing us to call people across the
world and eventually allowing us to
access information through web pages is
hosted on servers far far away an online
Network called internet today there are
1.4 million kilometers worth of cables
linking us all up and they transfer a
ton of data like the fastest cables can
transfer 224 terabytes per second and
the amount of data being sent around the
world doubles every two to three years
unsurprisingly there's a whole industry
dedicated to just laying down these
cables and then monitoring them and
repairing them when they break sometimes
they get broken by fishing trawlers or
anchors or natural disasters
sometimes they even get broken by sharks
though that's pretty rare but sometimes
these cables are broken on purpose
there's this island right off the coast
of China but it technically belongs to
Taiwan the country that China has vowed
to eventually absorb into their own
needless to say there's a lot of tension
here and in the last five years the
cables of this little island have
accidentally been broken 27 times which
is a lot for cables China denies that
they had any part in these 27 accidents
they say it's just an unfortunate
fishing or anchor incident but I'm
suspicious officials fear that Matsu is
just a warning and that internet
connections to the whole of Taiwan could
be under threat sometimes it's unclear
who attacks these cables like a few
years ago when somebody ripped out a two
and a half mile piece of this cable that
connects Norway to the island of
svalbard other times it's very clear
who's cutting the cables like when the
United States was at war with Saddam
Hussein in the 90s and they cut saddam's
cable so that he couldn't communicate
I mean cutting the communication cables
of your enemy is an old strategy they
were doing that way back in like the
American Civil War but the the more
interesting approach to me isn't just
sabotage
there's another way that you can use
cables to your advantage if you are a
great power trying to control things
if you have access to submarine cables
which governments and militaries do you
can scrape through the insulation of
this cable you can splice in another
cable and you can duplicate the signal
and hear everything your enemy is saying
[Music]
the British Navy did this to a German
submarine cable out here in the middle
of the Atlantic during World War One the
Germans suspected that they were being
listened to so they sent all their
communication as complex codes but the
British had very smart code Breakers and
they were able to decrypt all of this
and discover a lot of Germany's secrets
and they discovered this secret plan
that Germany had to Ally with Mexico and
invade the United States this is one
reason why the U.S ended up joining the
war and it all happened because of
Submarine cable tapping
World War II took cable tapping to a
whole new level a more connected World
meant more opportunities for Vital
military information to leak out so the
U.S created a new agency where they
would tap in and monitor hundreds of
thousands of Civilian telegrams and
phone calls flowing through both the
mail but also through these submarine
cables I mean think about it it was a
scary time it was global war it was mass
destruction so Mass surveillance on your
people felt necessary in the name of
National Security even the insides of
envelopes are scrutinized for hidden
writing by these sensors this agency was
shut down after World War II but the
seeds of mass surveillance were now
planted
a few years later president Harry Truman
creates a new secret Department the
National Security Agency or NSA their
job was to secretly collect and analyze
communication happening in the country
communication that was not meant for
them spying on communication of all
kinds all in the name of National
Security
[Music]
by the time the United States and the
Soviet Union are locked in a cold war
spying becomes even more valuable even
more of a priority for these governments
and once again underwater cables become
a Target
the Americans built this entire spy
submarine which had a secret space set
aside for Intelligence Officers and a
giant computer they called this space
the bat cave of course they did a bunch
of like military dudes on a submarine
and they've got their like secret like
computers like we're in the bat cave I
can totally see it this submarine called
the USS Halibut had a little mini
submarine looking thing that was
actually not a mini submarine but rather
a pressurized chamber full of special
gas that divers would just sit in there
and breathe it was pressurized to feel
like the deep ocean so that these divers
could go out into the ocean and be 400
feet under the surface and their bodies
were ready for the pressure they used
this to secretly navigate to underwater
cables the one we know about happened
over here right off the coast of Eastern
Russia the divers would leave their
pressurized gas chamber they would
navigate this big clunky electric
listening device onto the cable it's
basically a giant 20-foot recorder that
would tap up into the cable and record
everything passing through they somehow
parsed through with the dozens of
different signals specific phone calls
between Soviet officials but of course
this is like the analog days so the
storage on this device would fill up so
they had to go back with their little
bat cave submarine every few months to
replace the tape they did this for 10
years this was called Operation Ivy
bells and we talked about it a little
bit in the whole Deep dive we did on
submarines but boy it just like never
ceases to blow my mind how resource
intensive this operation was
Soviet cable the Americans learned just
how scared the Soviets were by the
buildup of nuclear weapons this helped
them negotiate a Slowdown in the nuclear
arms race and even helped lead to the
end of the Cold War according to one
expert
by the early 90s the Cold War was over
the change of centuries the dawning of a
new millennium
but then came a world-changing attack
into the ultra-connected internet age
this new law that I signed today will
allow surveillance of all Communications
used by terrorists including emails the
internet and cell phones this government
will enforce this law with all the
urgency
of a Nation at War it is now my honor to
sign into law the USA Patriot Act of
2001.
[Applause]
in 2006 a leaked document revealed that
in a non-descript building in San
Francisco behind this random yellow door
labeled 641a the NSA had set up this
harmless looking box that tapped into
the fiber optic cables that traversed
the Pacific Ocean into Asia the phone
company at T had agreed to let them
siphon off the traffic that was moving
through their cables this seemed kind of
nuts that the U.S was tapping a cable
where all of our communication goes
through
we had no idea what was coming in 2013
Edward Snowden an NSA contractor
Unleashed one of the biggest leaks in
American history this is the greatest
hemorrhaging of a legitimate American
Secrets in the history of the Republic
and that is what we have been looking
through I mean there's a lot more
documents but we sifted through and
found the documents that show us that it
wasn't just one cable in San Francisco
being tapped the NSA was targeting every
single cable that touched the United
States a huge amount of global traffic
email text messages phone calls they had
cooperation from all these
telecommunication and tech companies to
do this Microsoft Yahoo Google Facebook
pal talk the hell is Paltalk who knows
but the NSA was tapping their cables
YouTube Skype AOL and even Apple by
2012. and their goal in all of this well
according to one of these slides the
goal was to sniff it all know it all
collect it all process it all exploit it
all partner it all in other words
according to another leaked slide to
master the internet
there's this one spreadsheet in all of
these leaked documents that really says
it here is this is a list a spreadsheet
of some of the cables that the NSA had
access to like we literally know which
ones I mean we have the data of all of
these cables we could literally map all
of these from the Southern Cross cable
that connects California to Australia to
the Apollo cable that connects New York
to France to the tiny cables that
connect Puerto Rico to the British
Virgin Islands All In All by 2009 the
NSA had stuck a probe in hundreds of
Submarine cables all around the globe oh
and they didn't do it alone the NSA
partnered with the OG masters of cable
tapping the British since the 1940s gchq
and its American equivalents have had a
relationship that is unique in the world
okay so there's a weird loophole thing
here U.S law allows the NSA to track
anyone outside of the United States but
there are restrictions when it comes to
tracking American citizens so to get
around that they turn to their British
counterparts the gchq so over the course
of a couple years in the early 2010s the
NSA is paying a hundred million pounds
in secret money to gain access to all of
this data this data that they call a
gold mine to exploit hundreds of
thousands of names over 76 000 geo
coordinates 194 million messages
collected per day and unlike the NSA the
British could actually spy on American
targets but the point is they were in it
to collect it all if information arrives
in the UK from the United States it's
governed by our laws the system works as
intended
[Music]
okay okay yeah it's a lot of data but
what can you do with 600 million phone
events worth of data like that's way too
much for any human to actually process
and this is where it gets kind of nuts
to me we've got this slide which by the
way I know that we're like dealing with
like really like top secret documents
but like they all have like clip art and
these like templatized Windows 95
looking titles freaking love it
[Music]
this slide this complicated wonky wonky
slide with this flowchart is the answer
to what they do with all of this data
but here's basically how it works
so the NSA gets all of this data of all
of our communication either from cables
or from phone companies they funnel it
through the central processing facility
called Pinecone
[Music]
this is presumably where they're
processing a lot of this data and trying
to find patterns the NSA says that their
job is to find suspected terrorists or
other people who want to do harm to
National Security and to do this they
use computers and algorithms to make
links between suspected terrorists and
their immediate Network the people they
call the people they talk to where they
are they say they only hold on to those
records and they throw out everything
else we don't know if that's true but
let's just assume it is and then once
it's all processed and sorted it goes
into a little searchable database called
X key score which is a very clunky name
but hey great graphic design once again
this is basically like a internal search
engine that catalogs all of the metadata
that has been assigned to all of this
call message geolocation information and
makes it searchable so you could pull up
a person a suspected terrorist and you
could find everything you need to know
about who they talk to where they are
what their emails say or in their words
anything you wish to extract it's all
searchable on this convenient platform
this allows them to do searches like
let's look for an Arabic font Google
query coming out of the tribal areas of
Pakistan and boom they're LinkedIn it's
all right here in X key score the
database because of the globally
connected world the NSA now has access
to this person that can see what
messages they're sending they can see
where they are right now assuming they
have their phone all searchable in this
convenient database accessible to
agencies from other countries and all
over the world the whole assumption here
is that in order to find your target the
terrorist the Spy whatever you need to
access all of the information this turns
metadata into a weapon of Modern Warfare
we kill people based on metadata
but that's not what we do with this
metadata
this Revelation all of these documents
this whole Snowden drama was a big deal
for a lot of reasons one of the things
it did is it made the location of cables
really important most of the cables were
going through the United States but
after this leak countries started to
look for alternative routes that
bypassed the United States like this one
that connects Brazil to South Africa and
then goes on to Asia so over the last
decade since these leaks the U.S has
become less and less the epicenter of
cable connection and you guessed it
there's another player in town who wants
access to cables China
is rapidly building out their worldwide
network of cables and they're doing this
they're Chinese state-owned companies
like Huawei and this is adding yet
another front in this emerging Cold War
tension between great powers that want
to lead the global system it turns out
that controlling and spying on cables is
a requirement for Global Leadership in
2023 who knew but unlike the US who
purports to protect privacy and civil
liberties but secretly violates them
China doesn't even pretend China has
built a society off of mass surveillance
and control of information like here's
actual footage of how China tracks the
movement of its population through
Visual recognition through cataloging
every face every car information is
power in this day and age and just a
couple years ago the U.S formed a new
special unit with intelligence and
regulation officials it's a group called
team Telecom and their job is to assess
any new projects any new cables and make
sure that that they aren't going to
threaten or weaken U.S interests for
example there was this one cable that
was supposed to connect LA to Hong Kong
it was being built by like Google and
Facebook and they were like into the
project hundreds of millions of dollars
into the project and this team telecoms
shut it down too risky we can't have our
Fiber Optic Cables going too close to
China lest they spy on us this is making
the map look really weird you used to
only have to have like one major set of
cables connecting countries but now
you're starting to see duplicates the
Chinese lines and the American lines
each building out their own network not
connecting to each other it's like the
perfect symbol of the tension that is
rising between these two superpowers the
bifurcated world that we're moving into
China is connecting these small remote
Islands laying down cables and these
Islanders are happy to have fast
internet even if it comes from China and
is probably being tapped the continent
of Africa the US and China are both
laying down on competing lines the
countries caught in the middle of this
understand what's going on two aspiring
hegemons vying for power each involved
in spying and sucking up information in
their own way but I guess it's worth it
because it means faster internet it
means connection to the world Russia is
even trying to get in on this with their
aptly named Polar Express cable and even
though the old school tapping into
cables in the middle of the ocean to spy
on your neighbor is kind of outdated now
there's some evidence that Russia might
be still doing this they've got this one
ship called the yantar it's a surface
ship that is generally understood to be
a spy vessel and it's been spotted on
the surface above where we know
submarine cables are near Ireland or
near Syria some think that they're just
tapping into them like the old days
maybe using one of these like mini
submarines but even if they're not
tapping into them their very presence
above the cable is kind of a threat they
could cut this cable at any moment the
US who is very good at submarines has
its own spy vessels the most secretive
one being the USS Jimmy Carter order and
we have no idea what it's up to Security
Experts speculate that it's probably
tapping into cables for some reason
somewhere at the bottom of the ocean but
a lot of people in the industry are like
no that's like so old days why bother
it's so much easier to just tap into
them on land you get way more data and
you don't have to go to the bottom of
the ocean meanwhile the private
companies in charge of these cables have
started to up their own defenses they're
taking all these extra precautions
including sending out these like
submarine drones that just spend their
time tracing along the bottom of the
ocean babysitting these cables and
making sure that there's no damage or
tampering going on
so I feel like I'm going to say what
I've said a bunch on the channel lately
which is we are entering a new chapter
in geopolitics
a globalized world is hyper connected
but suddenly and unexpectedly we're
seeing a new set of Divisions countries
not trusting each other anymore Nations
wanting to create their own separate
systems both economically militarily but
also with the infrastructure of the
internet a chapter where countries now
are more skeptical than ever especially
great Powers great powers that are
building their own infrastructure so
that they can communicate and control
information not trusting the other half
of the world to handle their data we see
navies with secret ships that cost close
to a billion dollars a piece and then we
see everyone else
caught in the middle and in the end most
of us just want fast internet connection
with friends around the world and a
feeling that we're safe
[Music]
alright thanks for watching today's
video just a little nugget here we we
did this video because we did the Deep
dive on submarines a few months ago I
don't know if anyone saw that but it was
in that reporting that we came across
the the spying element of all this and I
remember I asked all of you do you want
me to do this video and you all said yes
I got like so many comments that were
like yes and so we did it and that is
one thing I love about YouTube and being
an independent journalist on YouTube is
that I get to just ask you like I'm
talking to you and be like hey do you
want this and you're like yes and I go
okay and I make it and there's no like
corporate middleman who decides what we
make we make what you guys want to see
so as always you can
um Pitch us ideas and uh we will hear
them for those who want to support more
fully in our kind of more intimate
Community we have a patreon called The
Newsroom The Newsroom is a place where
you can support what we do here but you
also get in on a few benefits including
an extra behind the scenes video every
month where you get to see all of the
people in the processes and the
shenanigans that happen uh here in the
studio we have a big team and you get to
meet them if you you are a member of The
Newsroom you get access to my scripts
you get access to Tom Fox music but
really you get access to the warm fuzzy
feeling that you're supporting a YouTube
channel that is trying to make rigorous
journalism in a time where facts and
Truth are kind of eroding so if that
floats your boat we would love your
support we also have Luts and presets
which are like the thing we use to color
our videos and our photos you could buy
those and they help support the channel
we have a poster that I designed I'm
super into map projections like all the
different ways you can show a map shape
and I made a beautiful poster that has
it if you have that poster I think a lot
of you have purchased that poster we
actually sold out and we're reprinting a
new batch so they should be in there
don't quote me on that because they
could be sold out again but anyway if
you have that poster like tag me or
something I want to see what it looks
like out in the wild like I looked at it
on a screen for months and now I have
some here but I don't know what it looks
like out in the wild so share it with me
I think that's it anyway that's all I've
got thank you all for being here and
um I'll see in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
we'll
will many tons
the cable itself speaks a single
language to all that is the language of
friendship and cooperation between the
men and women of France West Germany
England and the United States who
conceived and brought to completion the
cable to the continent